let's see if we can rewrite 6 12
6 12 as a decimal and once again i
encourage you to pause this video and
try this on your own and i'll give you a
little hint see if you can rewrite this
fraction not in terms of 12 but in terms
of tenths
well let's just visualize this thing so
let's say that this right over here
let's say that this right over here is a
twelfth
so that is a twelfth and so let me try
to make 12 12. so copy and paste that so
that's 2 12
and that is 3 12
and that is actually let me just copy
and paste the 3 12.
so copy
and paste
so now we have 6 12 which i'll color in
a second
and now we have 9 12
and now we have 12 twelfths
twelve twelfths right over there and
what we care we care about six of these
twelve so this is representing six of
these twelfths so let me see if i can
color in six of them
so let me
let me go to let me see if i can
pull this off so this is going to be
one let me do a bigger paintbrush so one
two three
four five six that's right that's six
twelfths let me just color all of this
business in so there you have we have
represented our fraction
now how do we how do we represent this
thing right over here in terms of tenths
so the one thing that i might want to do
is well look
6 and 12 are both divisible by 6. so
what if we divide this not if we rewrite
this whole not in terms of 12 but we
write it in terms of halves well how
would we do that well we could say
we could call all of this stuff we could
call all of this stuff this is one half
and this is another half or another way
of thinking about it is we're taking six
of our twelves together and then we're
putting them together and we're turning
them into a half
so in terms of the number of sections we
have we're dividing the number of
sections we have by 6.
so let's do that
so let's divide the number of sections
by six so now we're only going to have
we're going only going to have two
sections we're only going to have two
halves
that right over there is one half
and that right over there is the other
half notice we had 12 12. now we're
taking six of those at a time putting
them together so now we only have two
sections instead of 12 sections
but those six
those six twelves what are they going to
be in halves well once again we took
where we're taking six of the things and
putting them together into one so we're
gonna divide that by six as well
divide that by six as well and so you're
this is going to be the same thing as
one-half and you see this one-half
you see
this one-half
right over here and notice all we did in
the past we had multiplied and divided
sorry in the past we had multiplied the
numerator and the denominator by the
same quantity to get an equivalent
fraction now we're dividing the
numerator and the denominator by the
same quantity to get the same fraction
hopefully this makes sense that one-half
is equivalent to 6 12. now why did i do
that didn't i say that i wanted to get
this in terms of tenths
and yes i do want to get it in terms of
tense but one half is fairly easy to
rewrite in terms of tense so let me let
me re-express one-half so one-half let
me write it like this
so one-half i could
i could i could represent one-half again
i'm gonna re-represent one-half
so let's say
this right over here
this right over here is clearly
one-half
so i'm just re-representing it
so i'm taking a hole
dividing it into two
and one-half
let me just color it in one-half would
be that right over there which as we've
already seen it's equivalent to the 6
12.
now i wanna write this as tenths so what
if i take each of those halves and i
turn it into five times as many pieces
i turn it into five times as many pieces
so let me do that so i'm gonna do it
into one
one
two
three
four and
five so what did i just do i multiplied
i now have five times as many pieces and
the one-half is going to represent five
times as many tenths so this is going to
be equal to five
five over
five over ten
five over let me do that in that green
color
five
tenths notice
six twelfths is the same thing as one
half which is the same thing as 5 10.
all i did here is i multiplied the
numerator and the denominator by the
same quantity 5 so i could get 10 in the
denominator and 5 tenths well that's the
same thing as
times 1 10. it's literally 5 tenths
and we can represent this as a decimal
or you could kind of say in decimal
notation
five tenths we know that let's say that
that is the ones place
and if we go one place to the right of
the decimal that is the tenths place
that right over there is the tenths
place and we have five tenths so we
would put a five right over there so
this could be rewritten as the decimal
zero
point five
0.5 now there's other ways you could
have thought about it you could say look
6 is half of 12 and so what is half of
10 well 5 is half of 10 and so 5 over 10
is the same thing as five tenths or
which is the same thing as five tenths
written as a decimal